[Applause]
in the tragic night
of 6 October 1996 rebels have
attacked our hospital at emirate the
Democratic Republic of Congo
more than 30 people killed patients
beat in their bed at close range
staff can not flee killed
cold blood
I could not imagine that this
was she had buses forced
leave the emirate in 1999 we created
the panzi hospital in bukavu where I
works today as a gynecologist
obstetrician the first patient admitted
was a rape victim who was given a
shot in his genitals the
macabre violence knew no
limit
this unfortunately born violence
never stopped one day like the others
the hospital made a call after the
thread a colleague in tears and blu ray
please send us quickly
an ambulance please hurry
you so we sent a
ambulance
as we usually do
two hours later the ambulance and
you
inside a little girl of just
eighteen months
she was bleeding profusely and was
immediately brought to the operating room
when I arrived the nurses
while tears the bladder of an eruption
on the genital tract his rectum and is
severely damaged by penetration
an adult
we pray in silence my god says all
that what we see is not true
tell us it's a bad dream
tell us that when we wake up, everything will be fine
but it was not a bad dream
it was the reality cd you
our new reality the republic
democratic of the congo
as for our baby arrived I
realized that these problems could not
not find a solution to the block
operative but that it was necessary to fight
against the root causes of these
atrocities
I have not been to the village of the cases you
to talk with men why
you do not protect your babies your
girls and your women
where are the authorities in these villages
to my surprise villager
knew the suspect
everyone was afraid of him because he
was a member of the provincial parliament and
enjoyed absolute power over the
population
for several months his militia
terrorized the entire village he had a
style and fear kills a defender of
human rights who had the courage
to denounce the facts the deputies
is drawn without consequence immunity
parliamentary allowed him to abuse
with impunity
these two babies were followed by
dozens more children raped
when the 48th victim arrived
were despairing with others
human rights defenders
we seized a military court
finally these rapes were continued
and judged as a crime against humanity
rape of bba vaults ceased
calls to panzi on May 6
the psychological and sexual future
reproductive genetics of his babies is
mortgaged what happened to kavumu
and which continues today in
many other villages in Congo such
that rapes and massacres to be blessed and
Kasai was made possible by
the absence of a state of law
the foundation of traditional values
it reigns impunity in particular
for the people in power
the rapes the massacre the torture
insecurity spreads the lack
of education create a spiral of
unprecedented violence
the bus lines of this perverse chaos and
organized was hundreds of
thousands of women raped over 4
millions of displaced people to
the interior of the country and the loss of 6
millions of lives
imagine the equivalent of all the
poverty the whole population of denmark
decimated the peacekeepers the
United nations experts have not been
spared several have died
in fulfilling their mandate the
mission of the united nations in republic
democratic Congo remain present
until these days so the situation
does not degenerate further
we are grateful to them
however
despite their efforts this tragedy
human being it pursues without all
responsible are not prosecuted
only the fight against impunity can
break the spiral of violence and we
we all have the power to change the course
Of the history
when and why
we are fighting are just you
majesty your royal highness excellence
distinguished members of the Nobel Committee
dear madam nadia
ladies and gentlemen of peace
it is in the name of the Congolese people that
I accept the Nobel Peace Prize
it's up to everything
it is to all victims of violence
sexual intercourse around the world
what gede 10 is taken it's with
humility that I present to you
raising the voices of the victims of
sexual violence in conflict and
the hopes of my compatriots I
take this opportunity to thank
all those who during these years have
supported our fight I think in
particular to organizations
institutions of countries friends to my
colleagues to my family and to my dear
wife madeleine
my name is dennis my mail I
come from a richest country in the
planet
yet the people of my country are among
the world's poorest the reality
troubling and that is the abundance of our
natural resources gold cobalt coltan
and other and néré strategically feeds
the source war of extreme violence
and abject poverty in the republic
democratic of the congo
we all love beautiful cars
the jewels the gadgets I myself have a
smartphone these objects contain some
minerals that are found here often
extracted in inhuman conditions
by young children who are victims
intimidation and violence
sex while driving your car
electric using your smartphone
admire your jewelry
think for a moment about the human cost
of making these objects as
that consumer the least that one
can do
as a consumer the least that
we can do
and insist that these products be
made with respect for dignity
human
close your eyes in front of the dramas
to be complicit it's not just
the perpetrators of the violence that are
responsible for their crimes
but also it is that they choose to
look away
my country is systematically looted
with the complicity of people who
pretend to be and our pillet leaders
for their power to loot for them
riches and their ticket fame to
spend millions of men of women
and innocent children abandoned in
extreme misery while the
profits of the nominees ray ended up on
the opaque accounts of an oligarchy
predatory
twenty years ago to the day
the panzi hospital I see the
consequences of this bad
governance of my country
baby
young woman mother grammar girl and
also men and boys violated of
cruel way often in public in
collective by inserting white plastic
or another saying objects
blunt dallaire genitals
I reported or details
the Congolese people and humiliated
abused massacre more than
two decades in the light and knowledge of the
international community today
today thanks to the news
information technologies and
communication
no one can say I did not know
not with these Nobel Peace Prizes
I call the world to witness and I
urge you to join us for
put an end to this suffering that makes
shame on our common humanity
the inhabitants of my country have
desperate for peace but
how to build peace on two
mass graves
how to build peace without truth
nor reconciliation
how to build peace without justice
neither repair
at the moment I'm talking to you about intake
self-help mold in the drawers
from about to new york
it was written after an investigation
professional and rigorous on
war crimes and violations of
human rights perpetrated in the congo this
investigation explicitly names victims
places but dates and fight
the authors it is report of the project
mapping established by the high commission
united nations human rights
described no less than 617 crimes of
war and crimes against humanity
and maybe even crimes of genocide
what is the world waiting for them to be
taken into account
there is no lasting peace without justice
but justice does not negotiate have the
courage to take a critical look
impartial on the events that
have been raging for too long in the
Great Lakes Region
let's have the courage to reveal the names of
perpetrators of crimes against humanity
to simply avoid them
continue to mourn this region
martyrdom let us have the courage to recognize
our mistakes of the past
let's have the courage to tell the truth and
perform the work of the memoirs
dear fellow Congolese
let's have the courage to take our destiny
in hand let's build peace conflict
let's build peace let's build
the future of our country
together let's build a better future
for africa
nobody will do it for us
ladies and gentlemen of peace
the paintings that I brushed you
offered a sinister reality but
let me tell you
the story of sarah sarah has been to us
transferred to the panzi hospital in a
critical state his village had been
attacked by an armed group that had
massacred all his family leaving her
only taken hostage she was brought
in forest attached to a tree or all
sarah days were raped
collective until she loses
knowledge
the rape bidc used as a weapon of
war and destroy of course sarah
but also his family his community
in short simply destroy the tissues
on arrival at the hospital
sarah could not walk us
hold up and could not hold back
nor her nice urine and that because of
the severity of his injuries
urinary genitals and digestive coupled with
an infection on added nobody
could imagine she would be a day
as he gets back on his feet
yet every day that passes and the
desires to continue to live shine in
their eyes
every day that passes and it was she
who encouraged the caregivers
year not lose hope
every day that passes and sarah it's
was beating for his survival
today it's a beautiful woman
smiling strong charming sarah stood
committed to helping people and a lived
a story similar to his
it received 50 US dollars a
allowance that our house transits
and dorcas grants women wishing
to build their lives on the socio
economic
today sarah runs her little
business
she bought a small lot the
mozilla foundation help with tons
to make a roof she could get
to build a home
she is autonomous and very proud
to be autonomous his story shows that
even if a situation is difficult and
seemed desperate the determination
with determination
there is always hope at the end of
tunnel if a woman like sarah
do not give up that they are us for
do them this and of course the story
said that it's nothing Congolese but there are
sahara in Central African Republic in
colombia in bosnia oniam a and iraq and
in many other countries in conflict in
the panzi world our program of his
holistic that includes support
medical psychological social economic
and legal watch worried even though the
road to healing is long and
difficult
the victims have the potential to
transform their suffering into power
they can become actresses of
positive change in society
this is the case already the city of joy
our rehabilitation center at
bukavu where women are helped for
spread their destiny to hand however
they can not do it alone and
our role is to listen to them as
today we are listening to madam nadia
death at an Indian your courage
your daring
your ability to restore hope
a source of inspiration for the world
whole but for me especially the
Nobel Peace Prize which is ours
awarded today will have no value
actual crate it can change
concretely the lives of the victims of
sexual violence
departure the world and helped bring back
peace in our countries
so what can we do
or
what can you do first this is
our responsibility to all to act in
that sense and act it's a choice it's a
choice to stop or not violence
Regarding key women whether or not there
a positive masculinity that promotes
gender equality in times of peace
as in wartime
to act is a choice to support or not
a woman to protect her or not from
defend his rights to fight or not
at his side in the country ravaged by
Conflicts
finally it's a choice to build
or not peace in the countries in conflict
to act is simply refused
indifference if it is necessary to make war
it's the war against indifference
that is eating away at our societies today
secondly we are all would be
vab lé vis-à-vis these women and
their loved ones and we all have to
appropriate these fights including the
states that have to stop hosting
the leaders who tolerated or worse
use sexual violence to
access to power
states must
states must stop them
welcome with the red carpets is
rather the states must trace a
red line against the use of rape
as a weapon of war
a red line that would be synonymous with
political economic sanctions and
prosecution
to do an act is just not
difficult
to do a right act is not difficult
it's a question of political will
thirdly we must recognize
the sufferings of the survivors of
all violence against women
in armed conflicts and support them
holistically in their process
of healing
here I insisted on repairs
it's these measures that gives them
compensation and satisfaction l air
allow to start a new life
it's a human right
I call the states to support
the initiative to create a fund
global reparations for
victims of sexual violence in the
armed conflicts
fourthly on behalf of all
widows of all the heads of the orphans
massacres committed in the republic
democracy of the Congo and all
Congolese peace loving I call the
international community finally has
considered the project mapping reports
and his recommendations that the law be
said this is where it would allow the
Congolese people in crying his
dead mourn his forgive his
executioners exceed his suffering and
plan serenely in the future
finally after 20 years of bestowal
blood
rape and massive displacement of
populations the Congolese people
desperately waiting for the application of
the responsibility to protect
civilian populations
when their government can not or
do not want to make them the people waiting
to explore the paths of a peace
durable
this peace goes through the principle crying
transparent free elections
credible and peaceful
[Applause]
at work the Congolese people build
a state where the government is at
service of its population
an emerging state of law capable of
to bring about sustainable development and
harmonious
not only the democratic republic
of Congo
but in all Africa let's build a
state where all the political actions
economic and social issues are centered on
the human being and where the dignity of
citizens and restore your majesty
distinguished members of the Nobel Committee
ladies and gentlemen of peace
the challenges is clear and it's up to our
scope for
for the sahara for women the
men and children of the congo
I send you an urgent call from
not just give you the prize
nobel of peace but to put you
stand up and say together and at high
voice violence in the republic
democratic of the congo
it's enough, it's too much peace
now
Thank you
[Applause]